oh how kind of a crisis going on lately
four years actually what kind of a
haircut do I want man like sometimes I
have a little one table sometimes I
don't know
you
I'm bringing my handsome haircut to
Indianapolis thermal one more
specifically Kokomo Indiana where all
great things happen yeah dude
of course get ready dog no man come on
man pop off the Oscar before any videos
one game call Batman picking a vlog yeah
thinks I'll feel the Omega so awesome
steve-o oh man all right Dixon let me
share a ride Los Angeles International
Airport we just saw Kourtney Kardashian
she went through the pre-check line we
went through the schmuck line you know
how we know that we're going to be okay
to get approved for pre chick status
meet which means you don't have to take
off your shoes you go right through all
fast is because we watched Snoop Dogg go
through that like a couple weeks ago
that was what we knew it's time to stop
assuming that I'm not allowed to go
through pre-check I'm pretty sure Snoop
Dogg's been arrested with loaded weapons
and drugs there boy right are we
boarding should we can't crow quits on
gate 43
and I got a hacky sack back don't make
it take a picture dude age this up
alright
you can't take a picture
okay here we go
hey Tom Tom Steve tell them what not to
do if they're taking a picture can't
sign up for this number we think that
are not with the glasses
ah piggy if I see you sign me
there
Kannapolis right Oscar blubber and right
out in here - morning low
[Music]
what I know there just landed
I'm thinking
ninety dollars for that cleanser thank
you so much ready I never paid for first
class for myself cause it's not my style
but if someone wants to upgrade me a
dime into this kind of thing doesn't
happen on a Carson daily basis
I made some crews out of here yeah um
come on we're seeing it that's Christian
Bale my hands is Ari I need to go wash
in the Farrah Fawcett yeah
all right day you win hey I'll say if
any of you fans out there want to see
this just heidi montag me in the house
[Laughter]
you win
just editing on the plane like it's no
big deal
like this
you push the fat
cool man
of course thank you Oh save it to my
friends
please do we love our duty in a
I was like the dream it sucks it sucks
so bad